monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
mes chers collègues nous accueillons ce
soir monsieur olivier dussopt tu
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics sur le plan national pour la
relance et la résilience qui a été
présenté ce jour à la presse en même
temps que le plan de relance allemand
par le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance
bruno le maire et olaf scholz
vice-chancelier et ministre des finances
de la république fédérale d'allemagne
alors que vous aviez présenté le seul
ministre le programme de stabilité
le 14 avril dernier avant sa
transmission à la commission européenne
nous avions souhaité que le parlement ne
soit pas tenue à l'écart de cette
présentation du pnr
la plupart des plans nationaux ayant
fait d'ailleurs l'objet de consultations
publiques dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne avant leur
transmission
nous sommes à trois jours de l'échéance
de remise officielle du plan à la
commission européenne et cette
présentation
même si elle est tardive est donc
particulièrement ou bienvenue et est
méritée en tout cas que nous réunion
réunit six en commission des finances
ovo entendre le plan national pour la
relance et la résilience est un document
destiné à l'union européenne et non le
plan de relance dont nous avons
longuement discuté dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour 2021
après validation par la commission
européenne et le conseil de l'union
européenne
le pnr permettra de bénéficier d'un
financement de 40 milliards d'euros dans
le cadre de la facilité pour la reprise
et la résidence qui prévoit pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne 312 5
milliards d'euros de subventions et 360
milliards d'euros de prêts
le plan doit pour cela respecter des
conditions relatives par exemple à
l'économie verte au numérique ou aux
réformes qui devront être mises en
oeuvre
vous nous indiquerait donc quelles sont
les grandes lignes de ce plan présenté
aux institutions
européenne et surtout dans quel délai
les financements pourront être débloqués
d'après votre document la france devrait
recevoir un préfinancement de 5,1
milliards d'euros dans les deux mois
suivant l'adoption du plan par le
conseil ecofin avant une première
demande de déplacements d'ici à la fin
2021 concrètement quelle part des 40
milliards d'euros annoncés pourra être
versée avant la fin de l'année par
ailleurs la lenteur du processus de
ratification des instruments juridiques
permettant la mise en oeuvre du plan de
relance européen pourrait elle avoir une
incidence sur ce calendrier de versement
enfin le document indique que la france
est résolument engagée pour la relance
de son économie et dans la poursuite de
la mise en oeuvre d'un calendrier
ambitieux de réformes
je cite pouvez vous nous détailler dans
ce calendrier ambitieux
cette audition m'a lieu uniquement par
téléconférence
elle est par ailleurs retransmise sur le
site internet du sénat monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie donc de votre
présence et je vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs quelques mots donc pour
vous dire le plaisir que j'ai à vous
présenter le plan national de relancer
et de résilience tel qu'il sera transmis
à la commission européenne
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président il
a été rendu public
conjointement avec le plan allemand et
un certain nombre de pays de d'états
membres vont déposer leurs plans
simultanément c'est le cas de
l'allemagne c'est le cas de l'espagne de
l'italie de la france et d'autres états
pour marquer la volonté commune et
partagée que les décisions européennes
et le processus de relance au niveau
européen puisse avancer aussi rapidement
que possible
nous avons deux objectifs avec ce plan
national et le premier est bien
évidemment de présenter l'épreuve les
investissements qui sont engagés dans le
cadre du plan de relance français et
dont nous souhaitons qu'il puisse
bénéficier du plan de relance européen
tous les ans
si ce plan présenté dans le pnr font
partie de la stratégie france trop long
ce que nous déployons depuis septembre
dernier et stratégies au sujet de
laquelle nous avons eu comme vous l'avez
rappelé des débats longs et je crois
approfondie lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances pour 2021 vous l'avez
aussi souligné monsieur le président
l'objectif poursuivi par la france est
d'obtenir un financement à hauteur de 40
milliards d'euros dans le cadre de ce
plan de relance européen 40 milliards
d'euros qui viendront donc diminuer le
besoin de financement par l'état du plan
de relance à hauteur de 200 milliards
d'euros tel qu'il a été adopté avec la
loi de finances pour 2021 je voudrais
préciser deux choses d'abord dire que ce
montant de 40 milliards d'euros est le
fruit d'un calcul est le fruit de deux
critères principalement un premier
critère qui tient compte du niveau et
l'évolution des pnb au cours des
dernières années selon chacun des états
membres est un critère qui tient compte
de l'impact de la crise du coc vide au
moment où la décision d'élaborer un plan
de relance européen a été prise c'est à
dire à la fin de l'année 2020 à un
moment où nous ne connaissions pas
nécessairement les développements
épidémique ne pouvions pas prévoir les
développements épidémique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
ce plan avant de vous dire comment nous
l'avons construit comment nous le
présentons traduit aussi une avancée
majeure dans l'intégration européenne
puisque avec l'adoption de ce plan a été
créée une capacité d'endettement commune
de l'union européenne au service du
rebond de l'économie et pour la première
fois l'union va emprunter directement
sur les marchés pour financer les plans
de relance européens avec un emprunt qui
sera progressivement remboursés par de
nouvelles ressources propres ressources
propres qui restent à définir a instauré
parmi les différentes pistes ont été
évoquées ressources propres qui sont
aussi au coeur des décisions qui doivent
être ratifiés par les différents états
membres
c'est donc à la fois une étape
historique mais aussi un pas majeur est
symboliquement très important qui a été
franchi au niveau de l'intégration rompu
le deuxième objectif du plomb et de
renforcer la résilience de l'économie
puisque c'est à la fois l'objet des
réformes que nous menons depuis le début
du quinquennat et une volonté partagée
avec la commission européenne
je conviendrais sur certaines d'entre
elles qui sont prévus dans le plan tels
que nous transmettons à la commission
européenne
ces deux objectifs
nous à la fois obtenir le financement du
plan de relance français à hauteur de 40
milliards d'euros et pouvoir renforcer
la résilience de notre économie sont
évidemment complémentaires et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous travaillons de
front en veillant à ce que ces réformes
structurelles pour la résilience soit
parfaitement cohérente avec le projet
politique que nous portons s'appuie sur
ce que nous avons fait s'appuie sur des
réformes sont en cours
je pense par exemple à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et envisage aussi un
certain nombre de dispositions aux deux
textes sur lesquels nous travaillons et
qui correspondent à l'orientation
politique qui est la nôtre
le plan de relance et de résilience que
nous présentons à la commission
s'inscrit très logiquement et s'articule
pardon très logiquement autour de trois
priorités la transition écologique le
renforcement de la compétiton
compétitivité et la cohésion sociale et
territoriale
ce sont là les trois objectifs du plan
de relance français ce sont aussi les
objectifs poursuivis par le plan de
relance européen ce qui garantit pour
nous la meilleure d éligibilité possible
des actions que nous menons aux
financements européens
pour ce qui concerne le premier axe
consacré au verdissement et la
décarbonation de l'économie s'agit
d'investissements qui permettront
d'accélérer la transition écologique et
ils représentent plus de la moitié des
40 milliards d'euros que nous
sollicitons auprès de l'union européenne
la commission avait fixé un objectif
pour chacun des pnrr s'agissait de
consacrer au moins 37 % des actions
listées dans les pnrr à la transition
écologique nous sommes à 50 9
ce qui garantit la aussi l'éligibilité
des actions que nous défendons autour de
la rénovation énergétique autour de
l'écologie de la biodiversité ou encore
des infrastructures et des mots l'idée
mobilité verte et des questions
énergétiques
je ne détaille pas à des sens d'abord
parce que le temps qui nous est imparti
ce soir ne le permettraient pas et ce
serait inconvenant
mais aussi parce qu'il s'agit finalement
des items du plan de relance que nous
avons examinées ensemble lors de
l'examen du plf 2021 le deuxième axe que
nous défendons a pour objectif donc de
renforcer la compétitivité et
l'indépendance tissu industriel et
productif français et nous sollicitons
dans ce cadre 5,6 milliards d'euros de
l'union européenne et financements
permettront notamment de renforcer les
fonds propres des petites et moyennes
entreprises ainsi que les pays mais
aussi d'investir dans les technologies
d'avenir ou encore dans la transition
numérique et elle se combineront avec
d'autres mesures du plan de relance
français comme la baisse des impôts de
production de 20 milliards d'euros sur
deux ans que nous souhaitons voir
pérennisées évidemment au delà de 2020
une enveloppe de financement européen
dédié à la transition numérique que nous
sollicitons dans le cadre de ce plan
s'élèvent à plus de 10 milliards d'euros
sur 25 % du pnr air france est la partie
française du prr plus exactement alors
que la commission avait fixé un objectif
à 20% minimum là aussi nous veillons à
ce que nos demandes soient parfaitement
concordantes avec les critères
d'éligibilité posées par la commission
enfin les investissements consacrés à la
cohésion sociale et territoriale ainsi
qu à l'investissement dans les
compétences et les emplois pourront
bénéficier d'un financement l'union
européenne à hauteur de 15 2 milliards
d'euros
il s'agit de beaucoup d actions que nous
menons en matière de cohésion sociale et
territoriale dans le cadre de france
relance et que nous soumettons ainsi au
financement par l'union européenne une
fois notre plan adopté
nous recevrons un préfinancement de 5,1
milliards d'euros vous avez souligné
monsieur le président puis des
versements annuels correspondant à nos
décaissement même si le début des
versements européens ne conditionne pas
le déploiement de notre propre plan de
relance nous souhaitons que la
ratification de la décision sur les
ressources propres qui conditionne le
début des versements européens soit la
plus rapide possible pour donner un élan
commun
alors elle relance des économies
européennes aujourd'hui 17 états membres
17 16 et 17ème en dix sept états membres
pardonnez-moi ont ratifié la décision
concernant les ressources propres et
ainsi autoriser l'union d'une part à
dépasser le plafond des dépenses qui
étaient prévues dans le cadre
pluriannuel financiers l'union
européenne autoriser l'union à aller
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
pour financer ses actions et enclencher
les processus de décisions pour définir
la nature des ressources propres dans le
cadre et dans la perspective du
remboursement des emprunts contractés
par l'union à partir de 1028 nous
souhaitons bruno le maire l'a rappelé
ses homologues européens aussi que les
états qui n'ont pas
ratifier cette décision puisse le faire
le plus rapidement possible les retards
qui peuvent être constatées ou en tout
cas la lenteur certains process honte a
mené à un décalage de notre espoir de
versement des 500 milliards d'euros en
juillet 2020 2021 à septembre 2021
ça nous paraît une date limite et si les
process de ratification sont plus
rapides
évidemment nous souhaitons que deux mois
de septembre est une date butoir qui
choses puissent intervenir avant au
autant que possible en fin d'année nous
aurons l'occasion de demander un
décaissement qui est des actions mises
en oeuvre dans le cadre du plan de
relance et nous espérons pouvoir
solliciter de l'union européenne le
versement de 4 9 milliards d'euros ce
qui nous permettrait d'obtenir dans ces
conditions un financement l'union
européenne à hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2000 21
je reviendrai si vous le souhaitez
monsieur présente sur le rapporteur sur
la chronique des décaissements tels que
nous les envisageons au cours des années
suivantes
c'est l'investissement que nous
souhaitons que nous mettons en oeuvre
dans le cas du paon fons relance sont
accompagnées de réformes qui visent à
améliorer la résilience de notre
économie et améliorer notre potentiel de
croissance
je souhaite revenir rapidement sur sur
deux d'entre elles la première porte sur
le renforcement de la gouvernance des
finances publiques
j'avais eu l'occasion d'évoquer ce sujet
là lors de l'audition au sujet du
programme de stabilité et de dire que
nous sommes favorables à une règle
pluriannuel pour définir un objectif de
dépenses publiques en volume pour fixer
un cap donner de la visibilité sur les
leviers de maîtrise de la dépense de
manière aussi lisible et cohérente que
possible mais les propositions loi
organique actuellement en préparation
devrons nous permettre d'avancer en ce
sens et me permettre de faire aboutir
d'autres avancées comme le renforcement
du rôle du parlement en matière de
contrôle et d'évaluation des politiques
publiques ou encore les compétences du
haut conseil des finances publiques
la deuxième réforme sur laquelle je
serai provenir est également liée au
renforcement du pilotage des finances
publiques elle consiste à renforcer
l'évaluation de la qualité de la dépense
publique évaluation qui sera conduite en
sortie de crise
pour nous permettre de donner la
priorité aux dépenses publiques à la
fois favorable à la compétitivité au
virage économique et numériques de nos
côtes de notre économie mais aussi à
l'inclusion sociale
cette réforme c'est un chantier
l'évaluation la dépense publique a
évidemment vocation à
prolonger des réflexions déjà conduites
jusqu'à présent et elles s'inscrivent
dans les réformes abouti ou en cours qui
permettent d'améliorer le service rendu
à nos concitoyens et l'efficacité de la
dépense publique
je pense notamment à la refonte globale
de la fonction achats de l'état à
l'extension du dispositif de ressources
mensuelles qui est à la fois porteur
simplification pour les assurés sociaux
mais aussi de gains d'efficience en
gestion et ces travaux seront conduites
seront conduits seront conduits
pardonnez moi dans le cadre d'un
processus ouvert et associant l'ensemble
des acteurs
un mot aussi pour vous dire monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
que la réforme des retraites qui fait
souvent l'objet de débats et dont il est
souvent question dans les débats et
compris les débats publics médiatique à
propos du prr apparaît comme un objectif
dans cette réforme sans qu'elles
apparaissent de manière d'atténuer
précisé d'une manière précise dans son
périmètre est dans sa nature
nous avons pris un certain nombre
d'engagements fermes en matière de
réformes de la gouvernance des finances
publiques d'évaluation du champ et de
l'efficacité des dépenses publiques et
donc des revues de dépenses nous avons
pris ainsi un certain nombre
d'engagements et que qui sont les
engagements connus de nos concitoyens et
notamment avec la mise en oeuvre soumise
un certain nombre de clauses de
conditions économiques et sociales de la
réforme de l'assurance chemin nous
savons que nous devons mener une réforme
des retraites vont l'amener à la fois
pour assurer une plus grande équité une
plus grande égalité entre les différents
assurés sociaux
nous savons aussi que nous devons la
mener pour garantir la pérennité du
système de retraites mais la commission
a accepté que cette réforme
n'apparaissent pas avec un jalon
calendaire et une définition qui aurait
amené à anticiper ou a présenté sur des
décisions qui relèvent évidemment de
décisions souveraines fois en termes de
propositions par le gouvernement que de
décisions et d'adoption par le parlement
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
réforme n'apparaît que dans la forme qui
est la sienne aujourd'hui dans le pnr
que nous transmettons et donc comme le
rappelle d'une volonté que nous avons eu
l'occasion d'exprimer que nous réitérons
aujourd'hui en matière de réforme des
retraites
je m'arrête là monsieur le président
pour le laisser place aux questions et
essayer d essayer évidemment d'y
apporter des réponses et j'espère avoir
pu d'ores et déjà partants seront
d'éléments de réponses à vos
interrogations liminaire
merci monsieur le monsieur le ministre
je vais tout de suite donné la parole
notre rapporteur général jean-françois
fou s'il veut bien mettre son
gros c'est pas parfait encore un
voilà ça y est c'est bon
active et voilà on m'avait coupé le
sifflet donc le seul présent le ministre
mes chers collègues bonsoir merci
monsieur liste pour cette présentation
fait l'écart vis-à-vis du sénat dans un
temps record puisque on n'a pas le temps
de se pencher sur les plus de 700 pages
la synthèse est intéressante et utile et
la plantation rapide que vous avez fait
tout autant
je voudrais d'abord une observation très
rapidement vous poser trois questions
je crois qu'on peut dire que ce prr
finalement il s'inscrit dans la droite
ligne vous l'avez dit de ce que nous
avions le voter vous avez évoqué le fait
que vous espériez pourvoir dès cette
année décaissé si tout va bien
10 milliards je note néanmoins un sujet
finalement de contremaître de
ralentissement dans le processus
d'adoption des ressources propres
puisque vous avez dit que à cet instant
17 des 27 pays membres ont adopté
je ne souviens que le ministre clément
boon avait été beaucoup plus optimiste à
l'époque de l'adoption au sénat puisque
il espérait adoption total pour le juin
on avait quand même à l'épaule considéré
qu'il était peut-être un peu optimiste
la première question donc dans les
discussions ont finalement entre ce
qu'on a adopté en septembre 2020 dans le
cadre du plan de relance
et aujourd'hui on pas les discussions
avec la commission européenne ont-elle
éventuellement conduit à modifier
certains des projets contenus dans ce
plan de relance en tous les cas en
ajouter de nouveaux je l'aurais une
question sur la mise en oeuvre
maintenant de ce plan de relance j'avais
à les pondre souhaité qu'ils soient le
plus possible territorialisée et que en
même temps on ne perde pas de temps et
j'avais ainsi
sur le fait que dans un plan de relance
comme le nom l'indiqué bien il est utile
et nécessaire que les crédits puissent
être rapidement mobilisés puisque c'est
la condition quasiment sinéquanone d'une
efficacité dans la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan de relance alors je vais vous dire
que j'ai quelques inquiétudes et ce que
vous en faites pas parce que j'ai
récemment dans laquelle local de
contrôle que j'effectue sur les piges
yeux j'ai passé une journée dans mon
département les différents acteurs et
notamment avec des chefs d'entreprise et
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que à ce stade
les autres un point de vue une
expression unanime qui confirme les
craintes puisque dans les appels à
projets qui sont lancées à destination
des tpe et des pme dans le cadre du plan
de relance selon lankaises ont conduites
à peu près aucune entreprise aujourd'hui
ne peut répondre alors que pour plus de
90% le tissu économique vous savez dans
nos départements et le fait de pme ou de
tpe gêne aucune question nationale
comment comment pensez vous comment
comptez vous assurer la participation de
tous et notamment de toutes les
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
les grandes bien sûr mais également les
petites et les moyennes et ce sur
l'ensemble du territoire
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de dire d'un
comité de suivi
quand relance mises en oeuvre mais vous
y participer les familles liste de la
nécessité également peut-être de
développer plus rapidement des grands
plans d'infrastructures routières
autoroutières mais également sur les
pompes
parce que c'est important pour les poids
public
enfin une question mais je veux relever
monsieur le ministre le fait que ce pnr
r finalement il a une semble avoir une
marque bien française d'une grande
complexité dans le portage administratif
de suivi émises envers parce que si j'ai
bien compris à lire des codes et des
finances qui est chargé de la mise en
oeuvre du plan
faites en comment dirais-je en
concertation avec le secrétariat
européenne et avec l'appui des préfets
au plan local
et puis pour les réformes prévues par le
brr chaque ministre est concerné avec un
conseiller dédié qui assure le suivi des
mesures qu'ils concernent et le suivi de
l'atteinte de ce que vous appelez les
jalons doit être réparti entre le
secrétariat général france relance par
le ministère de l'économie des finances
ou par le secrétaire général de scapa
gélas aux affaires européennes selon la
nature de la cible
enfin la direction générale du trésor
doit piloter le rapport annuel remis à
la commission européenne
j'espère qu'on est bien d'accord et que
mes collègues ont bien suivi
est ce que le seul ministre cette
architecture vous paraît de nature à
garantir avec efficacité la mise en
oeuvre et les deux commandes scanner ou
n'est-il pas possible de le rendre
peut-être plus facilement lisible et
donc plus efficace
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
vous propose de répondre aux rapporteurs
jeu du mal mais pas si monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
je vais vous répondre aussi rapidement
que possible d'abord pour dire que les
discussions nous avions ouverte avec la
commission européenne sur le contenu du
pnr français ont effectivement commencé
très tôt puisque dès lors que nous
avions acté larchitecture du plan en
france relance tel que nous l'avons
présenté le 25 août avec bruno le maire
nous étions capacité d'ouvrir les
discussions informelles au départ est de
plus en plus formel ensuite avec la
commission sur l'éligibilité et là la
compatibilité des actions mettons en
oeuvre en france relance avec les
priorités communautaire et donc avec la
possibilité d'obtenir un décaissement de
fonds à hauteur de 40 milliards d'euros
lisez des discussions que nous avons
eues avec la commission n'ont pas amené
de changement sur la nature du pnr
c'est ce qui explique que l'intégralité
des mesures que nous présentons dans le
cas du pnr pour obtenir un financement
européen sont des mesures qui
apparaissent dans la maquette france
relance tel que présenté le 25 août et
les trois priorités du plan français
france relance
étaient les trois mêmes priorités que le
plan européen
ce qui explique cette compatibilité sur
la deuxième question le plan de relance
est déjà engagée évidemment à date
environ une trentaine de milliards
d'euros qui ont fait l'objet d'un
engagement dans le cadre de france
relance et c'est d'ailleurs la
démonstration que les difficultés qui
peuvent être rencontrées ici ou là où
les lenteurs des procédures concernant
la ratification la décision de son corps
cela ne nous empêche pas de mettre en
oeuvre le plan france relance et donc de
soutenir l'économie
même si je le répète nous souhaitons que
cette ratification sur la plus rapide
possible
nous souhaitons que la validation des
pnr et d'une autre en particulier soient
les plus rapides possibles pour obtenir
le décaissement de la vence hauteur 13,1
de 13 % sur 5 milliards sont aussi vite
que possible
si nous avons fixé une date butoir à 6
chambres nous serions très heureux que
le premier versement la première main
qu'on soit plus rapide concernant les
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
parfois des tpe ou des pme pour l'accès
au dispositif des aides non pas au
dispositif du prr mais au dispositif de
france relance et dont certains
apparaissent dans la nrf
je suis prêt à prendre quelqu'un aux
illustrations en avoir le coeur net dans
la mesure où nous avons la chance en
espagne et moi même c'est sur ces
questions de relance de rencontrer
beaucoup de tpe pme qui sont lauréates
d'appel à manifestation ou d'appels à
projets mais il peut y avoir ici ou là
des difficultés malgré l'implication que
je salue au passage
mais que je salue très sincèrement des
réseaux consulaires pour nous aider à
faire la promotion du plan auprès de
tous leurs ressortissants
quelques quelle que soit leur taille
enfin sur le pilotage
les éléments que vous avez rappelé du
pilotage sont les éléments du pilotage
de france relance en ajoutant pour ce
qui concerne le décaissement et
l'obtention des fonds européens
l'intervention du sg à eux qui va jouer
le rôle d'intermédiaire si je puis dire
ainsi auprès des autorités européennes
afin de démontrer que les mesures que
nous avons présentées dans le pnr et que
j'ai rapidement rappelé tout à l'heure
etc
de manière beaucoup plus précise dans le
document qui est long on vous l'avait
appelée vous l'avez souligné donc très
précis le sg heures à la charge de
démontrer à quel niveau nous sommes
engagés et à quel niveau nous avons tenu
les engagements qui apparaissent dans le
pnr pour obtenir le déblocage des fonds
année après année où semestre après
semestre puisque nous avons la
possibilité de demander deux versements
de fonds par an je je je je n'ai rien à
ajouter ou enlever est ce que vous avez
dit je confirme simplement que chaque
ministère a dû se doter d'une équipe
spécialisée en tout cas dédié pour la
mise en oeuvre du plan france relance
que les enveloppes territorialisée
notamment des concentrés font l'objet
d'un suivi par les préfets de
département et le préfet de région
il nous semble que dispositif mis en
place nous permet d'atteindre cet
objectif d'engagement et nous permettra
de tenir l'engagement qui a été pris
dans un décaissement autres 50% du plan
d'ici la fin de l'année 2021 et cylia
décaissement hauteur de 50% du plan ça
veut dire que l'engagement sera plus
importants d'ici la fin de l'année 2001
merci monsieur le ministre mais
maintenant donner la parole à nos
collègues le promettre week end est
suivi de vincent segouin michel mercier
le président vous m'entendez très bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
trois sujets et notamment pour féliciter
qu'il y ait des actions sur la
transition numérique c'est extrêmement
important pour la modernisation de notre
économie sur les questions de rénovation
énergétique j'ai quelques inquiétudes
est-ce que les 5 milliards 8 qui sont
prévus sur yron vu de l'engouement
observé actuellement mais surtout le
problème sur les matériaux pour pouvoir
réaliser ces opérations de rénovation
thermique qui flambent au niveau des
prix et donc qui risque d'altérer la
capacité à réaliser des programmes
deuxième chose sur les énergies vertes
où là aussi il ya des soutiens
extrêmement fort dire de faire attention
quand même à ce que la normalisation ne
conduisent pas à rigidifier les règles
de réalisation des projets j'en parle
notamment pour les questions relatifs à
la méthanisation il ya des risques de de
rigidification de la réglementation qui
conduiraient à ne pas permettre la
réalisation des projets et puis dernier
sujet c'est sur la compétitivité des
entreprises
est-ce qu'il est envisagé qu'il y ait
une réduction des charges sociales cas
on s'aperçoit qu'il est extrêmement
difficile d'être compétitif à l'échelle
internationale et si l'on veut remettre
la balance commerciale en positif il
faut que nous soyons concurrentiel et
nous voyons là le poids des charges
sociales
c'est vrai qu'un effort est fait sur la
baisse des impôts de production mais il
reste encore le coup de les charges
sociales voilà ce sont des
préoccupations voulait inscrire merci
merci michel vincent ce one lui
christine lagarde
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je voulais rebondir par
rapport à vos derniers propos sur la
réforme des retraites nous avait parlé
qu'il fallait bien cette réforme des
retraites puisqu'elle vous étés plus ou
moins imposée par l'europe avec plan de
relance ma question est simple c est ce
que c'est mon indépendance budgétaire
des états va rester ou est-ce que
dorénavant nous serons soumis au
contrôle de l'europe
les choix budgétaires qui seront pris la
deuxième question c'est par rapport aux
fraudes dédiée au renforcement de la
compétitivité
on constate aujourd'hui que la france
est un des pays qui le sait le plus d
industrialiser et je m'aperçois que le
l'enveloppent qui est dédiée au
renforcement de compétitivité est quand
même relativement faible par rapport à
un enveloppe de l'écologie où la
cohésion sociale et des territoires
je m'inquiète donc sur la relance réel
tel qu'on l'entend et si on à valeur
ajoutée qu'il en découlera suite à 7,7
comment ce l'emploi de deux de ses fonds
ou la relance merci merci vincent
christine lagarde puis pascal savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président dans la
suite de notre édition du 14 avril
j'ai essayé d'aller voir si justement
dans ce pnrr j'allais trouver des
réponses sur les mesures prises pour
assurer le redressement des finances
publiques et notamment j'avais en tête
les les commentaires pays qui avait été
fait sur les deux programmes paix
précédent 2009 et est en 2020 et j'avoue
que en allant regarder ce que vous
exposez en réponse alors que dans les
annexes c'est quasiment la page 710 de
dudu pnrr surtout sur tout ce qui est
les politiques structurelles vous
apporter des réponses alors après on
peut discuter de leur efficacité de
l'efficience savoir si mais vous
apporter des réponses qui semble coller
avec le sujet
j'avoue que sur toutes les réponses qui
sont apportées sur les recommandations
qui veillait à maintenir les dépenses
publiques affecté les recettes
supplémentaires au désendettement
là je suis beaucoup plus dubitative et
vous fait état de petites mesures celles
que vous avez déjà évoqué le 14 avril
devant nous notamment le plan d'achats
dans les administrations publiques
voilà c'est un
comme mes collègues plutôt un une
impression parce qu'on n'a pas eu le
temps de lire l'intégralité du document
mais je me demande si on a des vraies
mesures qui vont nous permettre de
retrouver une stratégie a payé
trajectoire pardon de finances publiques
soutenables
merci christine pascal savoldelli oui
bonsoir monsieur le ministre
bonsoir aussi à mais mes collègues je
suis assez enfin je voulais vous dire
monsieur le ministre
après les manches nous parler de réforme
les retraites et d'assurance chômage pas
sincèrement
bon je pense les éléments de langage qui
doit vous êtes commun mais parler de
générosité sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou jeu je trouve que quand même
c'est c'est assez extraordinaire
je rappelle monsieur le ministre que
dans votre projet il y a or au regard
relance mais y'a résilient souci comment
vous allez expliquer à des dizaines de
milliers de français qui vont perdre 15
% de leur rémunération alors qu'il
gagnait moins de 2000 euros
c'est les conséquences de la sueur et de
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage
je suis pas sûr jus même assez certains
que ça ne soit pas un élément de relance
mais excusez moi monsieur le ministre
mais en quoi c'est un élément de
résilience la deuxième chose c'est sur
la partie sur l'investissement de santé
dans les territoires alors là je vous
avoue parce que quand même il y avait
des centaines de pages à lire et à dans
un temps alors record donc qu'est-ce que
vous choisissez en fin de compte nous
parler des besoins structurels du
système de santé français post crise
sanitaire on nous parle de 2 5 milliards
du ségur à destination des hôpitaux donc
hélas je lis vos différents paragraphes
sur les concernant les questions de te
sentais qu'ils sont quand même la
première préoccupation a juste dit de
nos concitoyens je pense que c'est celle
aussi du gouvernement donc de donner
plus de place dans la guerre sur lequel
des soins mais rien sur la renforcer la
responsabilité des équipes médicales
pourtant sur une demande exprimée par
les professionnels médicaux de l'autre
côté je ne vois pas non plus sur la
question de la prise en charge des
personnes en résidence soit des miss à
domicile et tout ça c'est pas des sujets
subsidiaire quoi c'est à dire que
j'entends et je prends le fil de la
discussion qu'est la nôtre là il ya à la
fois des éléments de relance avec des
conceptions qui peuvent être différentes
sur comment on reçoit la croissance et
voilà monsieur luminis franchement où
est la résilience dans les propositions
qui nous sont faites avec comme l'ont
dit certains collègues une injonction
européenne je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci pascal sylvie vers billets
maintenant suivi de jérôme bascher s'est
lui même merci bonsoir monsieur le
président sur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre j'ai une question
en fait dans le prolongement
d'intervention du rapporteur général qui
évoquait la complexité de la mise en
oeuvre du plan de relance
nous sommes en début de mandature avec
des nouvelles équipes municipales qui
sont en train de phosphorer sur des des
millions ou des milliards de projets est
ce qu'il y avait pas une solution simple
qui était par exemple celle de doubler
la bo terre de doubler ou en tout cas de
l'augmenter de façon très conséquente et
pas seulement de se contenter du
milliard de dhs et si la d6 a été
augmentée mais c'est sans commune mesure
avec l'ampleur des projets que les
nouvelles équipes municipales conduisent
je prends l'exemple de mon département
du jura
nous avons une des deux terres de 12
millions à 4 millions de dhs et cl ça
fait 16 millions nous avons cette année
51 millions de demandes qui sont
exprimées par les communes je dis bien
51 millions de demandes de subventions à
deux projets
donc si on veut un une relance qui soit
rapide comme vous le souhaitez comme
vous les appelez de vos voeux
on sait très bien que les dossiers des
odr ils sont prêts à démarrer ils sont
instruits et je trouve que ça aurait été
une solution extrêmement simple pour
avoir une relance tout à fait
performante
merci merci sylvie jérôme bascher oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci pour votre présentation
effectivement à réussir à perry de
synthèse de 760 pages
c'était un tour de force d moi je
m'inquiète les 700 pages c'est à la
hauteur jeudi rue dépenses publiques
françaises
c'est très nombreux je suis pas sûr que
les 42 milliard réussissent réellement à
faire de la relance eu égard à peu près
tout actuels de dépense publique là où
40 milliards ça peut être le tireur un
pays qui dépense se peut et qu'il n'a
pas
la même taille que nous et je pense au
plan de relance italiens espagnols par
exemple eh bien je m'inquiète peut-être
justement de la fidh avant la faiblesse
de la mesure et il y aura d'autres
matches pas habituel est ce que ce sera
un vrai plan de relance c'est dire on en
profite et un petit peu pendant que
c'est des autres qui s'endettent cours
d'eau pour 40 milliards et puis j'ai lu
avec attention la déclaration commune de
bruno le maire et de la chaussure
jetable pas d'excusé pour eux sans doute
la mauvaise prononciation mais notamment
sur la partie recettes et notamment la
peau à 21% la comédie balle que vous
devez voir aboutir dès cet été j'ai bien
lu le xix stress qu'il n'ya pas sur le
volet recettes des sujets de relance
aussi à regarder et à faire et à
intégrer pardon pour les entreprises qui
me semblerait peut-être plus efficace
pour cet essai rejet j'ai peut-être pas
assez a séduit la faire merci merci
jérôme en cet instant je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes de prise de parole et
donc je vais me tourner vers vous
monsieur le ministre pour eux vos
réponses
merci monsieur le président simplement
pour répondre dans l'ordre des
intervenants pardon si cela peut vous
paraître décousu mais dira michel
canevet que pour ce qui concerne la
rénovation énergétique
nous n'avons pas d'inquiétude à ce stade
là le dispositif m'a pris man of
fonctionne bien si nous devions
peut-être avoir une seule inquiétude
ça serait plus justement le contraire
c'est-à-dire le rythme élevé de
consommation des crédits et la crainte
que les crédits prévus pour deux ans
soit consommer plus rapidement ça
s'inscrit aussi dans les logiques de
redéploiement que nous avons pu évoquer
à tel ou tel moment de la préparation du
plan de relance sur les questions de
compétitivité et l attente exprimée par
monsieur le sénateur d'une réduction des
charges sociales
nous n'avons pas prévu à ce stade ce
type de chantier faut tout de même
rappeler que nous baissons les impôts de
production de 10 milliards d'euros ce
qui est conséquent et d'ailleurs salué
par l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles que nous avons
pas très longtemps au début 2019
transformer le cic en allègement pérenne
de charges ce qui s'est aussi traduit
par un allègement supplémentaire et que
par ailleurs nous sommes allés déjà loin
en la matière puisque au niveau du smic
il n'existe plus de cotisations
patronales en tout cas et cela démontre
aussi d'un chantier qui a été ouvert il
ya maintenant plusieurs années que nous
avons je crois largement continue en
lien puisque je parle de cotisations
sociales
je voudrais dire à monsieur le sénateur
ce loin que la réforme des retraites
n'est pas imposée par l'union européenne
est loin s'en faut sinon nous ne
l'aurions pas initier présenté il ya
maintenant plusieurs mois avant qu'ils
existent cet épisode du coc vide est
avant qu'ils existent la perspective
d'un plan de relance européen et encore
moins laquelle la perspective d'un pnr
qui serait accompagnée d'engagements de
réformes nous nous considérons j'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire que cette
réforme est nécessaire pour ramener plus
d'équité et qu'elle est aussi nécessaire
pour garantir la pérennité du système et
qu' aucune des réformes qui apparaît
dans le programme de national de
relancer et de résilience est une
réforme imposée par la commission nous
portons nous mêmes des réformes nous en
avons porté nous en portons encore qui
converge avec les attentes avec les
orientations de la commission
mais la commission n'impose pas de
réforme à la france en la matière et
donc n'est pas lieu de s'inquiéter pour
la question de la souveraineté que nous
pouvons nous pouvons avoir
vous devez aussi dire à monsieur seguin
que les fonds ou les crédits qui
apparaissent dans le pnr pour ce qui
concerne le renforcement des pme des
deux pays des tpe qui l'a qualifiée de
modeste et comprendre la remarque
puisque dans le cas du prr ils
apparaissent hauteur 300 millions
d'euros sont évidemment très loin de
représenter ce que nous consacrons au
financement des pme et des tpe dans le
cadre de francs sera long nous avons un
objectif quand nous présentons ce
programme de réformes ce programme
d'action en matière de relance devant la
commission pour obtenir les 40 milliards
de financements c'est justement de
maximiser leur tour et de ne pas perdre
de recettes ou à prendre de risque de
passer à côté
une partie de ces 40 milliards d'euros
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
sélectionné parmi les
roger est parmi les actions de france
relance celles qui sont les plus
convergentes et les plus faciles à
présenter en termes d'éligibilité devant
la commission pour obtenir le
décaissement
il a fallu articulé cela avec un tram
d'exigence que j'ai là aussi rappelé
l'exigence de la commission qui est que
les actions du prr doivent représenter
au moins 37 % doivent pour 37% au moins
être consacré la transition écologique
et nous présentons dans le cas du pnr
des actions qui représentent presque 51%
du pnr pour la transition écologique une
devons aux yeux de la commission
présenté des actions en matière
transition numérique pour au moins 20%
du pnr et nous sommes à 25
nous avons ainsi sélectionner des
actions de france relance pour 41
milliards d'euros et il faudrait ajouter
les 60 autres milliards d'euros pour
prendre la pleine mesure des actions en
faveur de tel ou tel type de d'acteurs
de public notamment des pme et des tpe
madame la sénatrice labarde a évoqué la
question des finances publiques nous
engageons avec ce pnrr apporter de
réformes qui sont importantes et de
réformes que nous partageons et que nous
envisagions de mettre en oeuvre la
première est la règle la réforme de la
gouvernance des finances publiques
je n'y reviens pas j'ai évoqué ce sujet
là devant vous lors de l'examen du quai
stable de l'audition autour du stade
pardonnez moi cela nous amènera à nous
l'espérons disposer de avoir des
dispositions organiques permettant à la
fois d'introduire dans la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle et dans les
lois de finances annuelles des
dispositions qui reprendront cette idée
de norme de dépense de suivi de la norme
toutes administrations publiques
confondues de renforcer les prérogatives
du haut conseil des finances publiques
notamment pour lui permettent c'est
l'objectif que nous poursuivons d'exiger
du gouvernement
des justifications aux écarts qui
seraient constatés entre la norme
pluriannuel et le lard et le réaliser
pour ce qui concerne les explications ex
post et les prévisions pour d'éventuels
écarts a priori en tout cas avant
l'examen de telle ou telle loi de
finances ce sont des modifications qui
sont importantes et pour avoir une règle
qui serait plus contraignantes
nous devrions envisager une réforme
constitutionnelle en la matière je ne
sais pas si
tout le monde il serait tout à fait
disposé aujourd'hui il y a par ailleurs
un certain nombre de mesures qui sont
présentées je pense notamment à la
réforme du plan lâchage je ne partage
pas l'appréciation que vous avez porté
sur le fait que cette réforme soit une
petite réforme
nous espérons entre 800 millions et un
milliard d'euros d'économies et donc
cela commence à devenir extrêmement
conséquent et surtout à nous permettre
cela visent à nous permettre de réaliser
des achats dans meilleures conditions
n'ont pas cette année ou l'année
prochaine mais à moyen et à long terme
de manière à ce que cette fonction soit
plus efficiente enfin considérant
concernant le redressement des finances
publiques et le retour à un niveau de
déficit proche de 3% ce qui reste malgré
tout un déficit la trajectoire présenté
par le ps table et celle à laquelle nous
sommes attachés
je n'y reviens pas nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger à ce sujet là
pour ce qui concerne les remarques de
monsieur salvodelli deux points d'abord
un premier point pour dire que la
réforme de l'assurance chômage est aussi
une réforme qui va mettre en place un
bonus malus qui bat qui a pour objectif
de désigner désinciter si vous
l'autorisez ce barbarisme auront recours
aux contrats courts et en cela elle
porte un ensemble de dispositions qui
nous paraissent un tir intéressant
pertinentes et relever d'une forme de
résilience
mais la résilience que nous recherchons
concerne l'ensemble des acteurs ne se
résume évidemment pas à cette seule
question ni à cette seule réforme elle
se trouve plutôt dans l'ensemble des
réformes qui sont présentés dans le pnr
qu'elles ont été qu'ils aient été menées
jusqu'à présent qu'elles sont en cours
de mise en oeuvre ou qu'ils soient
prévues dans les mois et dans les années
qui viennent pour la qui sont la santé
dans les territoires
je vais faire une réponse assez proches
de celles que j'ai esquissé en réponse à
monsieur loin sur le financement des pme
et des tpe le ségur et et l'acte majeur
et permet de retracer à la fois les
revalorisations salariales à hauteur de
presque 10 milliards d'euros mais aussi
les engagements l'investissement pour
plus de 6 milliards d'euros ainsi que le
travail de désendettement les hôpitaux
avec une moitié du désendettement
consacré moitié la reprise de dette par
don consacré un désendettement pur et
dur et une moitié consacrée au
financement de nouveaux investissements
nous avons inscrit dans le pnr r d
engagement hauteur de 2 milliards 5
passes qui nous paraissent relever très
directement d'éligibilité aux
financements européens
mais ça n'est évidemment pas les seuls
éléments qu'il faut prendre en compte
est la réalité de l'intention de
l'intention et des interventions du
gouvernement en matière de santé que ce
soit dans les territoires où un niveau
plus global se mesure au travers du
ségur et des éléments que nous apportons
d'éditer des crédits que nous apportons
pardon au système de santé
je pense aux 20 milliards d'euros de
relèvement par rapport à lons dame qui
était prévu début 2010 21 débit 2020
pardonnez moi et qui ont été amenés au
cours de l'année 2020 je pense aussi aux
crédits que nous allons devoir amener au
cours de l'année 2000 21 à la fois pour
faire face au coût de la campagne de
vaccination coup de campagnes de tests
ou encore au surcroît d'activité dans
les hôpitaux du fait de la prolongation
de la crise épidémique mais en tout cas
il ne faut pas si vous me permettez
cette expression peu péremptoire ne faut
pas résumer on réduire notre
intervention matière de santé dans les
territoires au seul crédit qui sont
inscrits aux seules actions inscrites
dans le pnr se sont simplement celles
pour lesquelles nous sollicitons un
financement européen
j'ai bien entendu la proposition de
madame la sénatrice vermeille sûr pour
ce qui concerne la délétère jeu j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire dans différents
débats je ne partage pas totalement et
je considère que ce qui a été fait à la
fois avec un milliard de décines
exceptionnel consacré à la relance lors
de l'adoption du plfr 3 en juillet
dernier et avec un presque 1 milliard
950 millions d'euros consacré le décile
rénovation thermique dans le cadre de la
loi de finances pour 2021 sont déjà des
actes qui sont extrêmement importants
cela permet d'augmenter de presque 50%
les crédits habituellement consacrés au
soutien à l'investissement des
collectivités du bloc local communes
intercommunalité qui s'élève
habituellement à 2 milliards d'euros je
voudrais ajouter mais sans revenir sur
les débats relatifs aux paix stable que
nous avons eues que d'une part ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte où les
collectivités dans leur ensemble peuvent
s'appuyer sur une épargne brute réalisée
en 2020 est telle que constatée est
égale à celle de 2018 donc marquée par
un recul vis à vis de celle de 2009
d'environ 7 5 % pour les communes et les
intercommunalités
mais qui reste à un niveau 2018 qui est
plutôt un niveau très correct pour
permettre ce finances et enfin ajouté
deux points pour dire que la ds il
relance notamment telle qu'elle a été
mobilisée depuis le mois d'août dernier
puisque nous avions veillez à ce qu'elle
soit reportable sur 2021 fait l'objet
d'une répartition en fonction de
critères d'éligibilité qui sont les
mêmes que ceux là d eau terre et nous
avions veiller à bien souligné que cette
décision relance pouvaient être
mobilisés tant pour des projets
habituellement éligibles à la dsi
classique qu'à la dernière classique de
manière à écarter personnes
nous avons aussi dans le cadre de la
déciderez neuve rénovation thermique
laissé un délai supplémentaire aux
communes de plus petite taille ont leur
donner le temps de déposer des aussi
ainsi de ne pas être écartée et et je
souligne que pour ce qui concerne la ds
il relance et les perspectives
concernant la déciderai 9
le rythme de consommation des
autorisations d'engagement comme des
crédits de paiement est plus rapide que
ce que nous constatons habituellement
sur le rythme de consommation des aveux
et des cp de la dsi classique et la
dernière classique ce qui démontre à la
fois la mobilisation des collectivités
mais aussi leur capacité à s'approprier
ces ces outils enfin pour les questions
et les points évoqués par le sénateur
basher je pense que c'est 40 milliards
sont très utiles je ne sais pas si l'on
peut considérer que quand ces 40
milliards ne serait pas suffisant pour
dynamiser l'économie ce que je sais
c'est qu'ils vont permettre à la france
de faire face plus facilement à
l'engagement de plan de relance à
hauteur de 100 milliards d'euros
tant de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
auquel il faut évidemment ajouter
lorsqu'on est dans un exercice de
comparaison internationale les mesures
du plan d'urgence que nous mettons en
oeuvre depuis maintenant plus d'un an et
auquel il faut aussi ajouter un certain
nombre de dispositifs communément
appelés les amortisseurs sociaux lorsque
la comparaison est faite et ça n'a pas
été votre cas monsieur le sénateur avec
le plan de relance américain
il faut aussi avoir en tête le fait que
les dispositifs d'activité partielle
d'assurance-chômage de protection
sociale qui sont en vigueur aux états
unis sont sans commune mesure avec ce
que nous avons pu mobiliser et compris
au titre du droit commun sur ce qui
concerne les recettes je n'en reviens
pas sur la baisse des impôts de
production très simplement souligné que
les déclarations de bruno le maire et de
son homologue allemand concernant le
taux d'imposition à 21%
s'inscrit en soutien à l'initiative
prise et annoncée par l'administration
buydens états unis porté au sein de l'os
et des e/s qu'il s'agit véritablement
d'avoir un débat au sein de l'os et des
oeufs pour assurer un taux d'imposition
minimal qui pourrait être à 21% qui
seraient dans ce cas là au delà de ce
qui est envisagé jusqu'à présent au delà
évidemment de ce qui était envisageable
avec l'administration trump est
l'expression bruno le maire ce matin
visa a confirmé le soutien apporté par
la france à l'initiative américaine en
la matière cette convergence serait de
bon aloi et la fixation des taux
d'imposition minimal au sein de l' ocde
serait aussi utile est en tout cas
paiement utile que le travail que nous
menons pas ailleurs sur la taxation des
gars fera toujours dans la même enceinte
et là aussi avec une position
l'administration américaine qui a évolué
c'est une évolution que nous allions en
espérant qu'elles permettent aussi
rapidement que possible une
harmonisation qui seraient utiles à
chacune des économies concernent merci
merci monsieur le ministre merci d'avoir
pris le temps aujourd'hui de venir
devant la commission des finances du
sénat pour présenter ce plan national
pour la relance et la résilience
nous allons bien sûr donné dans les
jours qui viennent le travailler de
manière approfondie nous reviendront
peut-être avec des questions plus
complexes tout cas merci de cette
audition de ce soir vous souhaite à vous
même monsieur le ministre monsieur la
porte en général et à mes collègues une
excellente soirée
merci à tous
[Musique]